72 ساعه توصف بالذهبيه انتهت والنافذه
الاكثر احتمالا لانقاذ ارواح شارفت على
الاغلاق وفق معظم خبراء الكوارث
فالوقت ليس لصالحهم بل يضعف الامال بسحب
العالقين من تحت الانقاض احياء
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله اصوات خرجت من تحت الركام
في الايام الثلاثه الماضيه بعضها لحقتها
يد المساعده واخرى صمتت تدريجيا بعد ان
اتعبها ثقل الحطام وقسوه البرد فخسرت
المعركه نحن نسمع صوت من تحت الالقاب نسعى
جاهدين باتجاه النصل الى هذا الصوت ولكن
حقيقه البارحه يعني الوضع كان كارثي عند
مصل الى هذا الشخص نجده قد فارق الحياه
عوامل اللوجستيه عده عرقلت عمليه الانقاذ
ضعف الموارد ونقص المعدات والاليات
المخصصه للرفع ادى لاوقات استجابه بطيئه
وساهم بزياده عدد الضحايا لينقل ناشطون
اقدام اشخاص على حفر التراب باظافرهم
لعلهم يعثرون على ناجين
قاتل ابن عمنا لمده 30 ساعه كنا نستطيع
رؤيته ويمكننا التحدث اليه لكن لم ياتي
احد من الحكومه
العواصف الثلجيه تضاعفه الكارثه مع ملامسه
درجات الحراره الصفر مع عرقل عمليات تتحدى
نقص الامكانات اصلا
نادت من اول لحظه بانها بان الكارثه اكبر
من القدرات الموجوده عند الفوز البيضاء في
حقيقه نقص المعدات يعني ادى الى للاسف الى
فقدان الكثير من العالقين وفقدان ارواحهم
قصص نهار لا يمحوها ليل بل يزيد فصولها
قسوه وتعذيبا اشخاص تمسكوا لثلاثه ايام
بسماع اصوات شاكيه وباكيه هرعوا خلفها ثم
حضروا لحظات اختفائها تدريجيا
ضعف وقع المصيبه